[Musique]
bonsoir à tous sera vite vous retrouver
pour un nouveau numéro de mode d'emploi
votre magazine consacré à l'emploi et à
la formation professionnelle tout de
suite le sommaire c'est le futur centre
de recherche et développement de
l'informatique du futur le chantier de
ce site du groupe atos se poursuit plus
de 400 collaborateurs travailleront sur
lord a nié l'ordinateur quantique et sur
la cyber sécurité
un centre de formation à la sécurité
informatique c'est le projet de
l'entreprise silicum si la cour en 2020
nous avons testé un cours sur leur
plateforme de e-learning découverte de
la start-up auxi box une entreprise
créée en 2014
elle a développé des produits pour
sauvegarder et rendre invisible et
donner face à des attaques informatiques
rencontre avec son président fondateur
il a été lancé il ya un peu plus d'un an
le chantier du centre de recherche et
développement des clayes-sous-bois se
poursuit et se conclura à l'été 2020 ce
site accueillera plus de 400
collaborateurs
leur mission l'innovation dans le
domaine de l'ordinateur quantique et de
la cybersécurité reportage ce sera le
site de recherche et développement
d'atos aux clayes-sous-bois le bâtiment
diane 8000 m² dédié à l'innovation un
investissement de près de 5 millions
d'euros
donc ici une succession de
de meeting room à cet endroit là on fait
ensuite la bibliothèque et les pages de
cours la structure sur deux étages
accueillera entre 400 et 450
collaborateurs
une centaine seront embauchés deux tiers
seront des ingénieurs de recherche et
développement et l'objectif c'est de
créer aussi un acteur de ce centre des
espaces de partage des endroits où les
gens vont pouvoir se regrouper et puis
on va essayer de travailler dans une
vision plutôt systémique décide des deux
de nos machines de nos serveurs de nos
super calculateur de notre sécurité
plutôt que sur une vision très si l'hôte
et des supercalculateurs informatique
l'ordinateur quantique la cyber sécurité
et les innovations de rupture les futurs
thématiques de recherche notamment les
ingénieurs travailleront sur l'avenir de
la quantum learning machine c'est une
machine qui simule le comportement d'un
ordinateur quantique sans avoir
d'ordinateurs quantiques sans avoir de
cul vite et ça c'est vraiment très très
utile parce que ça permet de tester le
comportement d'algorithmique anti que
l'on développe et que l'on fait tourner
et ça permet de se préparer
la fin des travaux est prévue à l'été
2001 le déménagement des équipes sera
étalée sur le deuxième semestre de
l'année
elle promet la sauvegarde de nouvelle
génération des données informatiques la
start-up auxi box se développe depuis
2000 14 à saint quentin en yvelines une
gamme de solutions pour se protéger face
aux menaces des cyberattaques
nous avons rencontré françois fut chassé
directeur et fondateur d'auxi boxe c'est
un acteur de la cyber sécurité sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
un nouvel acteur auxi box une start up
créée par françois feugeas et je suis
avec vous justement bonjour bonjour
alors vous êtes fondateur de cette start
up
elle a été créée qu'en et en quoi
consiste cette activité alors auxi boxe
a été créé en 2014 avec une mission
simple qui est de pouvoir garantir à
toutes les entreprises quelle que soit
leur taille leur capacité à récupérer
toutes leurs données et à redémarrer
tout leur système
après un sinistre quels qu'ils soient et
y compris après une cyberattaque look
cibox elle est là alors l'oxi boxe a
effectivement c'est un modèle saas est
un modèle qui est étanche et ignifuges
dont qui amène aussi un niveau de
sécurisation en local qui est qui est
assez important on a des modèles qui
peuvent être déclinés pour tout type de
problématique pour tous types
d'entreprises dont qui peuvent démarrer
sur des modèles extrêmement léger puis
aller vers des très gros systèmes on a
stocké plusieurs pétaoctets de données
alors vous l'idée c'est que vous arrivez
pas après l' attaque ou pendant la tac
vous arriver avant la taxe et ça on
arrive avant l' attaque dans le sens
effectivement il faut que nos solutions
soient soient déployées avant l' attaque
donc elles vont permettre d'historiser
l'intégralité des données de
l'entreprise donc ces données elles
peuvent être stockées sur sur différents
types de supports stockées sur des
menaces elle peut être stockée sur des
serveurs des savoirs physique et ça va
au virtuel des postes de travail je
pense qu'on a tous des données sur sur
nos ordinateurs portables par exemple et
c'est le cas dans la plupart des
entreprises donc nous on va être capable
d'absorber l'intégralité de ses données
et de les restituer
après une attaque et également de
redémarrer les systèmes en un clic après
une attaque
vous êtes combien au sein de cette start
up à auxi boxe on est 10 à l'heure
actuelle et on existe depuis 2000 14 10
personnes c'est quel métier on retrouve
dans cette start up
alors on retrouve des ingénieurs
évidemment j'en suis j'en suis à moi
même on retrouve des techniciens
également pour assurer le support et
l'opération de nos deux de nos solutions
et on retrouve des rôles commerciaux et
marketing pour évidemment assurer la
diffusion de nos solutions
on sait que la cybersécurité c'est un
enjeu fort c'est dans les années déjà
depuis deux trois ans dans les
prochaines années aussi ça va devenir un
enjeu encore plus important
quelles sont vos perspectives de
développement dans ce contexte la roxy
boys réalise plus de 60 % de croissance
par an depuis plusieurs années
maintenant notre notre objectif et nous
internationalisé
cette année on peut en bénéficier à
saint quentin en yvelines d'un
accompagnement extraordinaire de la part
des équipes de l'agglomération est
également on peut rayonner facilement
sur l'écosystème extrêmement riche
en cybersécurité à saint quentin et plus
largement de toutes les entreprises de
saint quentin en yvelines
nos perspectives ça va être de créer au
cours des trois prochaines années
plus de 30 postes sur le pôle de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et également
sur notre second site de toulouse
françois feugeas merci beaucoup merci à
vous président et fondateur d'auxi boxe
elle collabore avec airbus cider
security pour développer leurs solutions
de cyber entraînement implantée à
guyancourt l'entreprise silicum sylla va
proposer des formations cours en 2020 en
cyber sécurité à travers une plateforme
de simulation d'attaqués informatiques
télé 78 à tester un cours les images de
patrick jacques de dixmude arthur
bataille bonjour bonjour vous êtes si yo
de silly comme s'il a alors silicone est
un acteur de la cybersécurité sur saint
quentin en yvelines
votre actualité c'est la plateforme
sylla de e-learning parce que vous
lancez un campus de formation
tout à fait on a l'espoir de lancer à
partir du premier semestre 2009 1 ainsi
bien lieu de cyber entraînement donc
l'objectif c'est en partenariat avec le
groupe airbus défense n space services
cybersécurité de lancer un lieu
d'innovation qui va permettre à des
étudiants de venir se former dans nos
locaux s'est dessinée à au grand public
là vous parlez d'étudiants c'est des
personnes qui ont déjà des connaissances
dans l'informatique alors dans un
premier temps on s'adresse plutôt à des
gens qui ont déjà une expertise dans le
milieu de l'informatique donc que ce
soit dans la partie réseau ou système et
après on évoluera pour faire des
parcours entre guillemets
d'accompagnement et de formation
depuis entre guillemets des personnes
qui vont être très novice dans le lieu
l'informatique jusqu'à un niveau
d'expertisé dans le domaine de la
cybersécurité en quoi vont consister ces
formations alors globalement on
utilisera la plateforme sylla pour toute
la partie learning et où
l'accompagnement sur les bases sur le
système d'information sur le réseau sur
la sécurité de manière générale et on
utilisera derrière l'accès à la
plate-forme d'airbus cyber security donc
la seule belge pour mettre en place des
cas pratiques et dessiner des scénarios
de crise dans le monde à la
cybersécurité un dernier mot vous dites
que ça sera lancée au premier semestre
2020 comment on fait pour s'inscrire
comment on peut participer à cette
formation assez simplement sur la
plateforme sylla
nous ont répondu à notre questionnaire
et notre formulaire de prise de contact
est également en nous contactant
directement sur notre site de guyancourt
les portes sont ouvertes n'hésitez pas à
venir d'ailleurs arthur bataille pouvoir
préparer une séance de formation avec
davy demontès oui exactement vous allez
être mis entre guillemets les mains dans
le cambouis et vous allez voir ce que
c'est le métier de la sécurité une
première initiation nous avons rejoint
david montes bonjour bonjour vous êtes
ingénieur pédagogique spécialisée dans
le numérique et notamment
vous travaillez pour sylla la plateforme
de e-learning deux formations à la
cybersécurité alors qu'est ce qu'on va
apprendre aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui nous allons devoir avec
sylla comment générer une attaque
surimpose windows ça c'est une façon de
tester les connaissances des gens qui
vous ne travaillez justement à rendre le
système plus robustes pour éviter les
attaques du coup ils vont voir comment
ça marche pour ensuite derrière ils vont
apprendre à se prémunir contre ces
attaques
alors comment ça se passe d'abord on va
d'un à plateforme sylla qui est notre
base de connaissances
nous allons voir on a participé r nous
avons audi pentest c'est justement la
partie que nous allons faire pour tester
les systèmes et nous allons voir un
cours qui s'appelle attaques simples sur
un poste windows
donc je vois durée totale du court 20
minutes avec plusieurs pré requis un
savoir utiliser une distribution linux
donc il faut avoir un minimum de
connaissances en informatique louis la
plateforme sylla se veut une plateforme
pour les experts pour apprendre à
renforcer leurs connaissances pour mieux
travailler dans les entreprises
c'est quoi une map et maps est un outil
de ce qui permet aux personnes qui font
des pertes est scanné le réseau
c'est-à-dire de voir qu'est ce qui est
possible qu'est ce qui est ouvert
quelles sont les différentes portes
d'entrée à un ordinateur ou un réseau
via metasploit qui intrigue morte c'est
à dire c'est une espèce de bibliothèques
d'attac qui permet d'automatiser les
attaques justement de qui permet de
lancer des façons simples des attaques
sur des équipes qu'on connaît
l'apprenant il a parcouru tout
l'exercice l'a vu ce qu'il faut faire
mais non il va sur la section exercice
du coup donc on va sur la plateforme
siberian d'airbus ça c'est les
ordinateurs qui sont sur ces réseaux
c'est une raison qu'on va attaquer on va
attaquer cet ordinateur
le plissé 4 oui à partir de duquel il a
d'abord on dit on va réaliser le cedi la
première partie le line-up le même map
on va faire le scan du réseau si nous
avons une deux trois quatre cinq six
sept huit neuf réponse notre réponse
d'ouverture donc de systèmes
potentiellement attaquable c'est un seul
système qui est neuf portes ouvertes par
lesquels on peut l'attaquer en peuvre
peut s'introduire on va aller vers m as
pelote metasploit c'est ce qui va
permettre ces carnets de fer l'attaquent
alors elle va consister en quoi cette
attaque du coup à s'introduire dans
l'ordinateur comme administrateur du
coup on aura le pouvoir de créer des
utilisateurs de leur donner les statuts
administrateurs
voir qu'ils soient qui sont les
utilisateurs utilisateurs on va voir
il existe le groupe administrateur
il existe donc l'attaqué réussite
l'attaqué réussie on a pénétré les
systèmes on a créé un utilisateur
on lui a donné des droits
d'administration il peut faire ce qu'il
veut
merci nous interdit de montes autres
formations proposées par numerix cette
entreprise installée à montigny le
bretonneux et spécialisée dans le
numérique et la cybersécurité
les premiers cours auront lieu en
janvier 2020 au ski cube
les détails avec cette séquence trois
questions à mon des rails a dit le
directeur général
l'université elle est spécialisée dans
la formation à appliquer au management
de la cybersécurité aujourd'hui la
formation sur la sécurité on va
commencer par la formation cryptologie
ces formations qui sera proposé par un
expert international dans le domaine de
la cybersécurité qui a déjà donné de
cours notamment au japon elle va avoir
lieu donc le 21 et le 22 janvier
et ça se passera à sky cube c'est une
formation qui est destiné aux cadres
déjà qu'ils ont des activités de
management transversal pour qu'il puisse
qu'on puisse les sensibiliser sur la
sécurité
nous constatons un besoin très important
il notamment donc veiller à nos
partenaires et nos clients
et aujourd'hui ça se justifie par à la
recherche de compétences notamment dans
ce domaine c'est la fin de cette
émission merci nous avoir suivis et à
bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]